buenas tardes como mencionas el gobierno
está altamente preocupado ya se han
confirmado
160 casos de la variante omicron hasta
el momento aquí en el reino unido- el
gran temor es que esta variante de lo
que se conoce hasta el momento es que es
altísima mente contagiosa mucho más que
la variante delta y eventualmente podría
poner en riesgo la eficacia de las
vacunas por ello a partir de este martes
7 de diciembre desde las 4 de la mañana
todos los viajeros que lleguen a este
país desde los 12 años tendrán que
presentar una prueba negativa pcr o un
lateral flow test tomado 48 horas antes
del viaje el reino unido para poder
garantizar el ingreso al país entonces
ya son dos pruebas pcr el lateral flote
este especialmente pero pcr es la que
más se pide para poder estar en el país
unas 48 horas antes del viaje y otra que
debe ser tomar el segundo día de haber
aterrizado en el país también se anunció
que nigeria ha sido agregada a la lista
roja de países es decir que no se
permite el ingreso de personas que
viajen desde esos destinos aquí al reino
solamente los nacionales británicos o
quienes sean irlandeses y tendrán que
estar en una cuarentena de 10 días en un
hotel el gobierno ha justificado estas
nuevas medidas en caída un alto link una
alta conexión entre los viajes
internacionales y los casos omicron
entretanto la agencia británica de salud
ha dicho que la ventana de infección y
síntomas es mucho más pequeña en el caso
de la variante omicron mientras como
mencionas en este país se han reportado
en las últimas horas 42 mil 848 nuevos
casos hobbits y 127 muertes relacionadas
y ya dentro del territorio británico el
premier boris johnson ha dicho que es
improbable que haya nuevos
confinamientos sin embargo algunos
sectores de la economía ya se han visto
golpeados cuáles son estos sectores
en realidad todos los sectores han
resultados golpeados porque este país ha
vivido en los últimos meses casi 3
confinamientos que han puesto en jaque a
varios de estos sectores pero uno de los
más golpeados porque en este país hemos
recuperado el sentido de la nueva
normalidad desde el verano es el sector
del turismo hoy las agencias de turismo
han expresado su malestar por estas
medidas de último minuto que han dicho
ponen en riesgo además a las personas
porque no han sido informadas con el
tiempo necesario para que se puedan
tomar estas pruebas pese a oficial que
son bastante caras han pedido además que
se bajen el precio de estas la
asociación de aerolíneas del reino
unido- ha dicho que es una medida
prematura que ponen en riesgo la
industria también el presidente de
british airways que la aerolínea más
grande de este país ha dicho que esta es
una medida fuera de sintonía con lo que
ha dicho la ciencia hasta el momento
pero lo cierto como mencionas es que los
científicos han advertido que
posiblemente después de las fiestas de
navidad pueden aumentar los casos porque
lo que se pide ahora es que se evite
todo de interacción social así que no se
descartan nuevas medidas mucho más
fuertes en este país